nous sommes à Gennevilliers pourrais
retrouver Guillaume bouberka il est
gérant d'une entreprise de traiteur
bonjour Guillaume vous affronter cette
5e vague de covid-19 avec beaucoup de
craintes et d'appréhension et pour cause
elle pourrait vous côté à votre
entreprise expliquez-nous pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement on a un gros
souci d'annulation des événements de
réception de veux des mères de fin
d'année et d'entreprise à cause du nom
regroupement et les gens ont peur de se
regrouper afin de se retrouver et de
fêter cette fin d'année tout simplement
et depuis depuis 15 jours on est soumis
à de très grosses d'annulation sur des
événements de 20 à 3000 personnes tout
simplement et ça devient très
préoccupant aussi bien sur le sur le
public sur le privé maintenant mais vous
évaluer les pertes financières
prêt entre 80 et 82000 €
sur le mois de décembre sur le mois de
décembre on se débrouiller se démener
pour essayer de trouver des vaccins mais
c'est pas les vacances nous empêche de
l'avoir Sébastien qui nous empêche de
grave il faut attendre d'avoir
certainement ce vaccin qui nous
permettra de recommencer à nous
retrouver mais nous pour l'instant là on
a besoin d'être aidé au prorata de ce
qu'on perd ça qu'on peut justifier nous
avez demandé d'annuler on est justifie
vous n'êtes pas suffisamment aider c'est
ça que vous me dites on n'est pas on
n'est pas suffisamment entendu
à Emmanuel Macron vous directement
c'était la dernière quand on était à la
deuxième vague et vous lui avez dit je
vais demander de l'aide
en fait ça résume un peu tout j'ai dit
que je voulais pas que ma société elle
ferme c'est une société de famille
Égyptiens et tu l'as réparé donc un
moment donné effectivement c'est avec
beaucoup d'émotion je vous parle je veux
pas lâcher donc je veux juste qu'on
écoute je vous laisse travailler
est-ce que le Président de la République
vous a répondu sur ministère oui comme
quoi effectivement ma demande avait été
entendu que j'aurai une réponse dans les
plus brefs délais ou que soit
effectivement il y aurait une annonce
par décret interdisant le regroupement
et c'est ce qui s'est passé mais du 1er
septembre au 31 septembre on était perdu
et c'est en octobre qu'on a interdit le
regroupement par décret et là
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on demande
est-ce qu'on a droit de se regrouper ou
pas vous avez pu bénéficier de ce PG ça
ça me plaît garantie par l'État il vous
a aidé comme il le fallait oui il m'a
aidé beaucoup parce que ça m'a permis
d'être un peu plus serein sur
l'évolution du métier et comment me
retourner face à la crise le souci c'est
que c'en est fini de ce PG maintenant
c'est l'année où il va falloir le
rembourser le problème c'est que si vous
ne travaillez pas ça va être compliqué
ça va être très compliqué on a eu la
possibilité de le repousser un an les
cas nous a permis cela je l'ai fait
parce que je ne savais pas où j'allais
et même s'il y a eu un engouement à
partir de septembre sur mon c'est où les
gens ont voulu se réunir exetera là ça
recommence à être une situation vraiment
très très préoccupante et je pèse mes
mots
au sujet de votre avenir totalement
totalement que ce soit en décembre ou
janvier totalement c'est pas des reports
c'est des annulations simplement
plusieurs mois sans son salaire
6 mois en fait son salaire donc bah on
mange des économies comme comme toute
personne
normalement constitué quoi un loyer à
payer j'ai des frais j'ai des petits
j'ai voilà je lâche pas comme ça il y a
un moment donné ça fait 18 ans que je
fais ce métier
non je tant que j'aurais pas tout essayé
je lâcherai pas je veux voir voilà j'ai
une conscience professionnelle
je veux
j'ai tout essayé on est en pleine
campagne
électorale avec des candidats qui sont
plus à l'écoute en tout cas que que
d'habitude si vous aviez un message à
leur dire ce serait quoi
d'être plus proche plus souvent de la
rue
des petites entreprises pas forcément
des grosses qui elle aussi mérite d'être
écouter pascal bras ce soit beaucoup de
personnel ou beaucoup dangereux qui soit
économique ou un humain mais il y a un
moment donné il faut écouter aussi
les les gens qui travaillent tous les
jours dans dans dans n'importe quel
métier et les politiques qui soit maires
députés
sénateurs que c'est vrai on en a besoin
il y a un monde mais il faudrait qu'il
écoute un peu plus dans l'année tous les
gens